I'm Austin Butler and this is working
title
and action oh chatty cafes do you have
this phrase in Iceland what a Chatty
Cathy is it's like
women talking now
what a great movie DD Gardner amazing
movie all right it's a strange
they had Irish in it so that's a good
guess there's only one film left is it
Irish estrangement or Irish
dismemberment banshees of inner shearing
boom I know what this one will be
king of Vegas king of Vegas no idea
listen we're just going to start with
baslerman
your answer no no
it's an amazing movie and I'm so proud
to be a part of this okay well we all
know what this is in its entirety
um I don't know maybe it's a movie that
we know very well it's got to be
everything everywhere all at once
everything everywhere
boom okay
this one I don't know fast and goose
the airplanes Tom Cruise because of
goose it makes me think of Top Gun talk
to me Goose talk to me Goose there you
go all right
gunk
Gunk
it's Kink it's with like a weird umlaut
Gunk what is that
like a star tall we didn't even discuss
it it's we don't need to discuss it
that's the only one I'm gonna get tar
tall tale truth
[Music]
Oh no you're gonna get my game show face
the whole time it's a fat woman cat
shoes making moves I'll let you
is it
sing boots
person
[Music]
looks like we favorite Puss in Boots
that's not cool we don't we love them
all the artists more except for turning
red which is the best
[Music]
wee bit loud is there a noisy
All Quiet on the Western Front
Crocs crustacean Crocs scallopers what's
a crustacean crustacean mussels Muscle
Beach no muscle the station Crux
sandals Sandals Resort the all-inclusive
Crocs
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
this has me stumped
the Sheep
woman
that's the hardest one circle square
triangle triangle of sadness it's
triangles
why did they invite me to this yay
[Music]
[Applause]